since I have a few extra minutes I
always like throwing a curve at the
beginning for both of you you have done
a lot of cool stuff in your careers
thank you uh and so if someone has never
seen anything you've done uh what would
you like them first and why besides
Eileen good
question you go first I can't remember
thing I've been in right
now I think I have to I I'm I have to go
at devil R Prada yeah I think if you're
going to start with one thing um I mean
I I'm so Overjoyed by the now Decades of
love that that film has received and
that it's for so many people it's it's
like a family member at this point and
it's it's kind of become part of the
cultural lexicon and so if yeah if an an
alien species landed and I had to start
with one film of mine I think it would
be you know I'd want to show them the
Chanel boots
um I
think I'm just going to say it again cuz
I said it before but there's a show I
did um called Life After Life That's
based on a Kate Atkinson book directed
by John Crowley which I'm really really
really proud of and I want more people
to
see including the aliens including the
aliens I think the alien
specifically would enjoy that I actually
think that' be a great thing to show the
aliens I haven't seen the series yet but
just knowing the book it's a beautiful
kind of human offering yeah Humanity I
think aliens would be like so that's
what humanity is that's what it's about
yeah yeah between our two films you got
a lot of it covered not everything but a
lot a lot one last question before
getting into why I get to talk to you
guys today you've both worked on a
number of things is there a day a scene
that you remember from one of your your
previous projects that you vividly
remember being incredibly nervous before
you stepped on
set
um literally you could throw a dart at
every day on set for me and find that
moment but yeah um I I just a moment
came to mind which was um I made a film
called Rachel getting married uh
directed by the one the only the great
Jonathan Demi and there's a scene in a
rehearsal dinner where my gives a speech
and um I was nervous that day because I
was giving the speech in front of some
people who knew the charact the person
that my character was based on and I
didn't know how I'd measure up and um I
remember turning to someone uh after I
did the first take and going I just have
to know how how does it you know stack
up and she gave me some feedback and it
pushed me way deeper bur into the
performance past the nerves past
everything else and it was a gift and
and I'm really I I I'm really proud of
my work in that in that scene and um but
I was I was very nervous that day
because anytime you're playing someone
real in front of someone who knew them
it's it's yeah scary yeah um I'm going
to say I did a film called last night in
SoHo and as the name suggests it was set
in SoHo in London last night last yeah
last night in so and uh there was like
we were filming a lot in SoHo and Soho
is a very busy place and uh there was
one scene where I was running through um
I think it was padilly circus and it was
just like insanely busy and every member
of the crowd they weren't a part of the
film they weren't essays or extras they
were just like the general public and I
was there like like with black makeup
running down my face and like just
looking in absolute mess sprinting
through the crowds running away from the
shadow men um and I got some pretty
weird looks on that day that was pretty
N
rcking I just love the sentence I was
running away from the shadow men yeah
yeah going to be all right darling it's
going to be all right just running away
from Men In general really yeah jumping
into why I get to talk to you guys
you're both so great in this and I'm
curious um when you're making a film
like this which is clear clearly not
Marvel money you know you're making it
on a budget do you feel more pressure on
yourself prior to stepping on set to
know all your stuff or you know what I
mean because you don't have as much time
and you don't have as many takes
absolutely yeah yeah I think I'd feel a
lot of pressure either way like if I was
on a Marvel project like just knowing
the amount of money that's going into it
I'd want to be worthy of that money um
like either and also like um if you're
making an indie film knowing amount the
amount of hard work and time that goes
into it I want to be worthy of that hard
work and time and sacrifice so either
way I think
that whatever the budget is the approach
that you describe that should be the way
you act I mean that that's kind of your
approach as an actor the thing that I'll
say when you're working on an indie film
uh versus like a super Lux you know all
expenses paid ride the per the people
that feel it the most are the
crew and so it's extra I feel like
there's extra emphasis on you as the
actor to really really really keep it
tight and do a great job and hit your
mark and be super precise on an indie
film because um the crew is everybody on
on an independent film has like 18 jobs
that are not their job and so you just
want to make it as easy on them as you
possibly can and the best way to do that
is to do your job as best you can to do
your work show up prepared so one of the
things about I'm so curious when you
were given the like this script how much
were you told about it because or how
much did they say just read this because
at a certain point this film punches you
in the face in a way that you're not
expecting and so I'm just curious how
much were you told about that in advance
uh or or maybe you'd read the book I'm
not sure hadn't read the book wasn't
told in advance I have um sort of you
know you have your your your list of
directors that you're just dying to work
with and Will was on that list for me so
it was a William older project that just
kind of had a part that was that I could
maybe play and uh that was everything I
knew going into it and like you said it
was a total um total gut punch and I you
know it was one of those ones where the
thing that happens happens and you're
just like wait wait what and you go back
a cou a couple pages and you and you go
oh my God I think I know what they're
doing and this is crazy and how do I get
involved with this this is
amazing yeah I wasn't warned I feel like
it's better not to warn people going
into it so that like their shock is like
as big as it possibly can be um so my
team sent it to me and was were just
like you should read this um and then
after reading the script and loving it
so much and and and so badly wanting to
be a part of it I went and read the book
and was even more in love on that note
um I got to stop I'm just going to say
you guys are both fantastic in this uh
thank you for giving me your time and
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating thank you so much have a
wonderful
day